because I like to go by what I know I
don't know about stats and all that this
man here was in a relationship thought
they'd be forever it got messed up he's
now co-parenting would he have chose to
be a co-parent in the beginning no no
you're going out there and you're
choosing the only reason why he's
co-parenting because he knows that by
co-parenting with his child's mother
will put his child at an advantage but
otherwise as they're doing what you're
doing you're putting your child at a
disadvantage but this is a guy that's
been there done it got the t-shirt and
you still won't listen selfie that's
selfie so previous instead of selfie
instead of falling and falling for the
Trap like he did of going through
somebody that you didn't get on in the
end and now you're comparing probably
having friction
wait wait let me land I would rather go
from the beginning and say okay we're
gonna have a baby it's like yeah girl
we're gonna have a baby we have the baby
and you come to your side I go to my
side and we co-parents